bonsoir des chefs comme vous le savez
avec les événements qui se déroulent à
hong kong
l'emprisonnement des deux canadiens et
les nombreux manquements face aux droits
humains en chine
seriez vous prêt à cesser les échanges
commerciaux si la situation ne
s'améliore pas merci beaucoup pour votre
question première réponse monsieur
bernier où est la priorité est bien
clair c'est de faire en sorte que les
canadiens puissent d'être retour au
canada est actuellement bien qu est ce
qui arrive c'est les relations avec la
chine qui sont très pas leurs meilleurs
sons peut dire mais pas seulement la
chine avec d'autres pays à cause du
gouvernement trudeau
donc ça serait une priorité comment
faire bien oui il faut avoir l'oeil de
nos alliés mais aussi en mettant
regarder nos relations commerciales avec
la chine
et ça peut être quelque chose qu'on va
évaluer pour imposer d'autres des tarifs
si jamais on n'a pas la réponse à ce
qu'on veut c'est rapatrier ces canadiens
là le plus rapidement possible et aussi
ce que je peux vous rajoutez sait que
c'est important de s'assurer qu'on est
des bonnes relations avec l'ensemble des
autres pays
ce qu'avec monsieur trudeau avec les
états unis on n'a pas la meilleure
entente et avec l'inde aussi cet angle
merci merci monsieur bernier monsieur
trudeau on reconnaît que la priorité
c'est toujours de défendre les intérêts
des canadiens et de défendre les
canadiens c'est pour ça qu'on a
justement fait activé tous nos alliés
autour de la planète pour mettre la
pression sur la chine pour leur dire que
non ça ne se fait pas de détenir de
façon arbitraire des canadiens pour une
raison politique
on va continuer de chercher à résoudre
c'est un jeu tout en reconnaissant que
la chine est une économie en croissance
qui prend beaucoup plus de place qui
crée des opportunités économiques pour
nos producteurs pour nos travailleurs
mais nous devons toujours être là pour
défendre nos valeurs nos principes et
c'est ce que nous allons toujours faire
merci monsieur trop dur mais ce chien
c'est pas une grande surprise que le
gouvernement qui ne respecte pas justin
trudeau après de son voyage désastreux
ya beaucoup des chefs d'état du g20 qui
ne respectent pas mr doit rien faire
pendant neuf mois pour protéger les
canadiens et canadiennes pour les
intérêts des canadiens
j'ai dit que quand premier jeu va
retirer l'argent canadien de la banque
des infrastructures asiatiques
il y a aucun sens c'est une banque qui
était contrôlé par le gouvernement de la
chine n'y a aucune bonne raison pour
l'argent des contribuables d'être aidé à
l'aide pour construire les ponts et les
roues dans les autres pays et qui
appuient la politique étrangère de la
chine
on va y revenir à ça monsieur things
will à la priorité si les canadiens qui
à ce moment sont dans une situation
tellement difficile donc il faut agir
dès maintenant pour les aider ça c'est
quelque chose qui qui est essentiel en
plus ce oui la question sur qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire avec la chine et forêts
de fort pour montrer qui on défend les
droits de la personne ce qui se passe
encore c'est tellement inquiétant le
fait que les gens à fond face des grands
auprès nations contre les 3 mai avec
monsieur trudeau encore voir qu'ils
doivent flashé à gauche pendant la
cabane du tout les bonnes choses mais il
va tourner un autre watts pendant qu'il
est au gouvernement
ce que je veux dire pourquoi elle a pas
arrêté devant des armes
merci merci nous avons un éléphant dans
la chambre c'est le parlement deux
dernières fois
et si jamais j'avais dont les débats de
prendre un set c'est pas un seul vote
c'est une traite ce serait énorme avec
les investisseurs de la république de la
chine qui a donné déjà les doigts des
entreprises de la chine de charger les
cadres
quand nous avons les lois que le chine
n'aime pas contre les lois pour protéger
l'environnement et c'est tout à fait en
secret c'est quelque chose
merci merci monsieur blanchet finalement
jamais dit moi d'avoir une pensée pour
les agriculteurs sous gestion de l'offre
de la circonscription de l'échangé de la
vallée du richelieu parce que de
mauvaises négociations commerciales rock
tv 2 points 4 % leurs parts de marché
après ça le gouvernement canadien s'est
fait l'instrument des états unis et ses
poignets une chicane avec la chine
malheureusement la réponse c'est qu'on
peut pas être chic en perpétuelle avec
un géant comme on peut pour jouer des
brocs avec la chaîne
malheureusement c'est impossible et là
c'est les producteurs de porcs de sawyer
de canola qui paie le prix de sa alors
malheureusement il faut maintenir une
relation commerciale avec la chine
j'espère qu'on pourra revenir aussi sur
un autre l'arabie saoudite le traitement
relève pas d'un oui la vente d'armes à
l'arabie saoudite saoudite qui choque
beaucoup de gens au québec
il faut que ça cesse merci monsieur
blanchet alors monsieur marcel merci
beaucoup de votre question